this show is brought to you by the cash
app the number one finance app in the
App Store you probably know cash app is
the easiest way to send money to your
friends but cash app does way more than
that cash app also comes with the cash
card a free debit card that comes with
boosts which are like instant rewards
for shopping at the places you already
love you can get up to 10 percent off
your entire purchase at door - and even
save every time you shop at Whole Foods
Target and more cash app is also the
easiest way to try and grow your money
with their new investing feature I'm
very excited about this because unlike
investing tools that force you to buy
entire shares of stock cash app lets you
instantly invest as little or as much as
you want this way you can still own a
piece of any stock with just one dollar
brokerage services Benton can you say it
brokerage services Wow good are provided
by cash app investing a subsidiary
subsidiary subsidiary o of square and
member seat32 sign up for cash app and
use the promo code Whitney not only will
you instantly receive $10 but the cash
app will also donate $10 to the trevor
project to keep me alive
an amazing organization that provides
crisis intervention and suicide
prevention services to l GPT oh my god
she that the new LGBTQ LGBTQ youth
across america what happened was I had
gotten everything right and then I
started to psych myself out right at the
buzzer so download the cash app from the
App Store today do it do it do it I
didn't
[Music]
please thanks Chris Dave things just
fall okay let's not deal with it right
down let's get this rocks Wow and then
what is that fresh pot that is if we
want to pull something up while we're oh
yeah while we're talking like if you're
like who is Whitney Cummings we can
google it he can and if you want to
Google something like Google Dave core
hole mm-hmm David Grohl you go David
David I was born David David mm-hmm
we can look shit up if we want to or not
wow this is fun thing comedy is dead so
podcasting is all we have left
bullshit Phoebe is dead how about though
really kind of so people just podcast
oh my god do you wanna hear some crazy
yes are we already doing this I think so
so one of my old friends from Washington
DC who was a punk rock kid when we were
punk rock kids back in the 80s he lived
in town and his brother was in a great
band called King face were really
awesome and he went off to college and
did stuff and now he's the editor of Bon
Apetit what Adam Rapoport whoa yeah and
I did his podcast talk about food yeah
cuz I do barbecue stuff oh I've heard
about yeah and so we so I want up on a
super foodie podcast you have a green
egg I have many green eggs yeah that's
like if I'm just kind of hanging out
doing stuff oh that's not like a fancy
one no then I've got like the big ones
okay yeah have you ever done a barbecue
competition no I feel weird about that
why well it's like having a drumming
competition or something
I guess I don't know it's it's plus I
you know I do it sort of recreationally
and then I will cook for people
sometimes sometimes I'll cater cook next
weekend for a thousand people at the
harley-davidson dealership in Santa
Clara no I've never been paid for making
food question is being a good drummer
lend itself to being a good barbecue er
well you get paid for that no I don't
miss things you know I have to be out
well this is sort of part of what I
talked about with my friend Adam
Rapoport was that cooking and preparing
food for people is not unlike making
music and performing for people very
true they're very similar very true in
that the preparation in making a recipe
or preparing something not unlike
writing a song and recording it and then
serving is like performing it's very
fulfilling to watch someone get
nourished by something you made not that
I've ever had that experience I think
you might be the same in that when you
go up on stage you go back to comedy and
stuff you want people to you're there
for them however I do think though
there's now that I've been doing
stand-up for a long time it hasn't lost
its joy but there's definitely more
pressure like doing something I didn't
get paid for or that people didn't buy
tickets for I feel like I would get that
feeling back does that make sense yeah
cooking for someone I think actually
might be even more rewarding to I do
stand-up at the Harley things come out
sure wait in Santa Clarita yeah isn't it
on fire hope not because of your
barbecuing I don't mean that yeah that's
her if I'm actually one of the first big
things that I did because I've been
cooking for a long time and and when
they had all those crazy Malibu fires
last year I was watching it on TV and um
and I saw these evacuation centers and I
was like oh man I should maybe I can
cook maybe I should go cook yeah at an
evacuation oh that's cool but then I
thought you know the last thing they
want to eat is some fucking smoked
brisket brain smoke out there evacuation
centers is not
yes yeah blackened cob yeah this guy
used to run our website became a fire
and firefighter cool my hero so oh my
god they're amazing so we went and we
got in touch with him and I made food
and delivered it to like eight different
fire houses fucking honor stations and
it was great yeah
but then I started doing like more and
more stuff like do something for the
food bank and then I did auction it off
so that I'd go cook for parties and
stuff that is so rad
like when you had kids and had to start
providing for little mouths like cooking
yeah well I've always been like a
Virginia barbecue dork hmm but not like
a serious one
were you a crab guy oh my god like
Chesapeake crab dude absolutely I got
the best place where here it's no you
can't get I've I've I've flown blue
crabs out here that's I have by flump
bushels of crabs because that's it's my
favorite thing in the world my friends
and I get in fights all the time cuz
when we go get sushi and they get baked
crab ham roll when you grow up in the DC
area you just you've had a level of crab
that no one else in the world can
understand there's something about
something about it we used to do we used
to go to Ocean City Maryland
oh so shitty Ocean City Delaware and we
would get my dad called it crab America
and we would go crabbing no it was so
fun yeah I used to go back every year to
Rehoboth with guy no I was in an ocean
city guy and then I was dewy and nice
dudes nice now okay it was pretty
sketchy back then and then there was
Bethany which we stayed a couple summers
jeez
Bethany Beach was like between Dewey and
Rehoboth and then because we're hobart
it was the most expensive one that was
the nice one and then I graduated to
Rehoboth they have like nice restaurants
and stuff there I used to take acid on
the boardwalk and go to Dolly's taffy
it's just eat taffy on LSD I got a
sunshine house and get some dolphin
shorts I really don't recommend it to
anybody and then go
the Gravitron did you ever go to
Gravitron you know they had this haunted
house in Ocean City ages ago it was
called morbid Manor and it was at the
very end of the boardwalk I this is like
I'm older video this is like early 80s
or mid 80s and so it was it looked like
the psycho house it was like a haunted
house
it was the most terrified they're ZnO
way they could do it now like a
liability there's no way they could do
it because again and you'd walk in at
you first of all in line for an hour and
there's this guy chasing people out of
the house with a chainsaw the whole time
he's standing in line and you're just
like I'm not going in there there's no
way and then you go inside and the first
thing you get into this room and it's
one of those spinny things where you
stick to the wall whatever they're on in
the thing and so you get in that and
there's someone in the like sitting in a
chair in the middle and then you run
through the house and people grab you
and then the only way out is to run
through this room that's filled with all
these like prosthetic bloody body parts
and a guy with a chainsaw you have to
get past the guy I think I was like a
bike chain on it like mutely Hill but
you have to get past him in order to get
out the thing it was amazing they could
still grab you they can still touch you
I think we can like in haunted houses I
scooter they would grab you I feel like
I just read something about this haunted
house that they shut down it might have
been in Birmingham Alabama where like in
order to go in you have to sign like a
40 page disclaimer liability thing
because what fun is it if no one's gonna
like you're going in there and what
about fucking Gravitron I can't I don't
think it's there anymore
because we used to get on in a wheel and
then you would stick to the wall yeah
and someone would always puke always and
the puke would go right back into your
face that's not not great I can't
believe that shit was legal a lot of
shit then we grew up doing I
they used to sell beer bongs in the
stores on the boardwalk in Ocean City
and they were like they're really cheap
there weren't good ones they were really
cheap and they had these tits they would
say like get bonged
like a neon funnel with a thing in it I
bought those like well into my 30s I was
buying those things I used to in DC we
used to have lawn darts little darts
that you would just throw into the lawn
and they would go into kids lay that's a
toy yeah that was a toy back when I was
a kid even slipping slice the rocks
hailing your asshole I feel like we used
to run and fly into slip and slides
that's a lawn dart remember those yeah I
do and kids would just like get them in
their shoulders and shit yeah crazy
those are the days
what about panic rooms have you ever
done one of those is that what they're
called escape escape panic rooms any
room I mean yeah that's what I call my
wine room at home I have not done one
personally but I've been with my
children in them and they could figure
it out and I can't so if I were ever to
be stuck in an escape it would save your
life they would say my lives I don't
want to do that I have no interest I'm
too competitive
what happened be fun I don't know how
they work but I just know that I'm
working so competitive all the time I'm
the person at game night who like ruins
the night because I get too competitive
you can't have fun no not at a game not
doing anything I don't think I like
ping-pong I get too angry if I miss it
makes me too frustrating so your problem
is you and all of these bad experiences
I personally I feel like it's your how
dare you it's not everybody else okay I
just I'm like I think that bowling my
I'm very good at bowling there's a great
bowling alley right down the street you
know that that was really fun where we
had that the Corbett Bowl korban Bowl
it's a bowling alley right down the
street it's fucking awesome I was kind
of pins pins is nice well now that
you're like you know Corbin Bowl really
is yeah because they have this karaoke
room in there that's fucking it's like
the voice you do karaoke fuck no I don't
like singing so those people take it so
seriously have you been in the Barney's
Beanery karaoke oh that's like people
that are like like yeah they're waiting
for an A&R guy scratch you know what's
kind of sad when I first joined Nirvana
the bass player Chris lived in Tacoma
Washington which there's not really much
pronounced to queima or is it I think
there might be a Tacoma but Tacoma okay
there's nothing there and so they're
like these weird sort of lounges and
taverns and bars where you would drink
yeah this is fucking 30 years ago but we
went Chris and Curt and Chris ex-wife
Shelly and I once went to this bar where
they had a karaoke thing and at the time
we were being kind of groomed by all
these different record companies we were
gonna bet it on by all these it's rank
gifts and shit Benihana so they but we
had so many and our guy cards but we got
wasted one night and gave an an or a guy
card to a karaoke singer is that
terrible what I I don't remember which
it was a occur or me or Chris and we
gave it to her under the impression that
we were in A&R guy we were gonna make
her famous I feel like baddest hot zo I
feel like that person still has that
card for Shore is on tick tock right now
trying to reach people what's tick tock
you don't know what tick tock is my kids
do are you on it I mean walk no I mean
did you watch them do you know what it
is I feel like it's 10 seconds of
something it is and it's basically
remember musically your kids are
probably on musically oh that's the one
where you do that thing here's what we
were kids where we would sing into the
mirror with our hairbrush and I would
like to sing along right to the music
they now record it upload it to the
Internet so that they are unemployable
ass dude I don't do - I've done one tick
tock you dude it I did it with Ke$ha
okay only because she has a song called
tick tock I'm familiar okay and I was
like you know what I'm gonna do it with
her because that's the only way I won't
feel corny this is tick tock I actually
looked up your music on it there's lots
of your music on it but I don't know if
it's you
oh my god that's not me dance really
lost the magic looking heart I don't
know are you gonna pay for it
except the Revenge of the Nerds version
somebody else does it but so do they
have to pay for this right I mean we
probably have to buy whatever that was I
have no idea you're about to get money
from us just playing this on the podcast
and that's all I get great fucking
coffee by the way what's going on in
here did you know about the coffee that
I told you about the fresh pot no though
copy that they that they get out of
civet poop oh I didn't fucking click on
it I drank it once
Paris nobody could figure out the coffee
machine in our house okay then someone
needs to go to Starbucks and get Dave
girl you know I was kidding about the
coffee I've had coffee but if someone's
going to Starbucks cray someone is going
to get up Dave Grohl here everybody pull
it together we also have frozen coffee
also who's this guy are you shaking in
your boots about this guy's lip sync on
tick so that's tick-tock to your music
or to anyone's music and they do it for
15 or 30 years come on I've only done
one I know hold on okay I'm getting it I
don't know how hold on I'm too old for
this this is mine so that's me see I
don't do any of this you know what I
really want to do do you know okay so I
don't do Twitter and I don't do
Instagram and I don't do Facebook I
don't know I'm just like late in the
game I just discovered Amazon like six
months ago I'm not kidding yeah that's
what people do that's what people do you
know they could just send it to your
house now I don't I don't know if I'm
comfortable with that Walgreens to get
batteries yeah we're like rubber gloves
Dexter got it anyway so I was gonna say
something Amazon tick tock amazon tick
I'm not on Instagram
yeah oh no there's the one where you can
you can put you could sell yourself for
birthday messages do you know that way I
did not do a cameo people that have had
a lot of people messages literally the
only reason I won't do cameo right now
is they tell publicly say the price of
what you love you we have more coffees
coming this is - we have to caffeinate
Dave Grohl hold on a second are you do
you think you're addicted to coffee me I
am I get a headache a little bit if by
10:00 a.m. I have it on my coffee I get
a full I have problem like what sir I
had to go to the hospital once for
drinking too much coffee yeah cuz I had
was having chest pains I thought I was
dying
this is 10 years ago whole fresh pots
thing yeah that was a route that was
real that was not that was a real thing
and I drank so much coffee over the
course of like three weeks yeah they
started having chest pains
and I thought I was having a heart
attack but we were about to go play at
the White House on the 4th of July I
know well so I thought so I put Bayer
Aspirin in my wallet and drink a lot of
red wine cuz I thought I booked up
online like I guess I could keep my cell
from dying and so went and played DC
came home called my doctor and I'm like
Mel I'm having chest pains right now dr.
Mel know and he's he's like are you
having him right now I'm like kind of he
was kidding here so I went in and he put
me on the thing and I'm like on the
treadmill and he's like doing a sonogram
and he was like I don't know I don't
know I can't find anything
you should get a cat scan I was or an
MRI or something so I go to Cedars and
they put me in the MRI thing the thing
and they do the the cat scan thing and I
come out and the doctor sits down with
me with the computer thing the and the
readout is like they turns it on it
except for 10 seconds he goes how do you
I said I'm Fortas 10 years ago I was 40
I said I'm 40 he goes okay why are you
here yeah I said I'm having chest pains
and he goes all right and he basically
went down the list he's like are you
under any stress
I sleep like three and a half it's
terrible anything to drink you drink
coffee
dude and so he said that I should to
caffeinate
I tried quit I tried to quit coffee and
I was in hysterical apoplectic fits
every day couldn't do it
do you watch the ASMR videos can you
allow us to sleep you know I came home
one night and my kid was in my oldest
daughter was in a living room asleep and
that was on TV with and so I walked in
and all I heard was cuz in my house
right now and it was a girl with a with
a mannequin head brushing there no like
massaging the I just had a microphone on
it or something and it was just girls
just like massaging this man and my kid
was dead asleep I'm like this is fucked
up and I sat down and watched it for 45
minutes no tingling it's just kind of
annoying yeah I think that makes me
physically ill it's disgusting like that
cars song hey guys you kept it going I
have lots of questions for you okay do
you have any questions for me I'm just
kidding
you know no let me get my own fucking
podcast you should I should now be
amazing you could have a cooking
barbecue pod yeah I just try to sort of
hide from the world come on so social
media your nightmare
well I understand it's it could be
useful when you want people to know
stuff correct so like if we make a song
yep
then if we put it on there then people
know we have a new song I don't
necessarily feel the need to tell
everyone when I'm what you're having
taking shit or whatever so but I get it
I understand why people would but it's
not really my thing do you let your
daughter's on it they are yeah and then
what was the logic like when did you
decide it they were ready I'm terrified
of being a parent for this exactly yeah
it's you know it's I think everybody
kind of finds their way mm-hmm doing all
of that kind of stuff has a lot to do
with their friends has a lot to do what
they're interested in it usually begins
at the project I'm gonna do a project
can I get an Instagram account because I
want to do a project with horses I'm
gonna have my own horse YouTube channel
yeah and then it you know and then he
wind up in front of a mirror with a
thong I think is what happens I don't
know so yeah I mean it is is it YouTube
or do you have to control what is
watching on YouTube by your kids yes you
have to pay attention also you know it's
just so different now I mean I like when
I when I was a kid growing up in
Virginia like I was listening to satanic
death metal okay and my nice public
school teacher mom was just like honey
could you turn it down so you know I
don't and I wasn't like running around
town stealing stereos and smoking crack
or whatever but I was I bet in
Georgetown in Georgetown yeah rough
streets of Georgia
oh my fancy shit now Georgetown used to
be cool you walk down now it's
Restoration Hardware it's J there's a
j.crew on every corner we got 42 well
you know what's funny is I was there
this weekend and at one point I went and
did this thing the citilab thing
and after that we're all like yeah let's
go to lunch so we went to Jose Andres
place
I think it's called Jaleo or Jala Oh
something like that anyway it's on 7th
Annie and 7th Annie is where the old DC
space used to be d a space with people
and I would say we were saying outside
the restaurant I didn't even realize
where we were and I look like 17 e this
is a DC space and I looked and it became
a Starbucks oh it hurts my heart isn't
it hard and 14th Street 14th Street man
yes
no it's fancy there's lots of like
bistros like Parisian Bistro so I went
there it's my heart a little bit because
it you used to be able to say like I'm
from DC and people like oh yeah that's
badass and now they're like mmm
cool so you love Banana Republic it's
changed a lot very preppy now actually
you know the old 930 Club I think you
came a j.crew I love you you can't do
that a little bit more over a little bit
more over middle of the block
anthropology no they sell denim jackets
yeah jkerner with birds on that's it
anyone allowed this to happen
DC lost its fucking edge now damn it
that is heartbreaking that's sad that's
really I think that was the hallway that
went back to them I made a lot of
mistakes on that property I did you got
a blowjob phase right there oh my god
that I met you and I first kind of I
feel like became friends there's
something about its oat milk
it's not milk no it's delicious not milk
that should be their tagline not milk
yeah I find oat mok's a little whatever
this is I feel like when we first met
when I meet someone from DC I feel like
they're like instant family
for sure right we instantly started
talking about the Wiz yeah oh my god I
have a question about that
it used the whiz had a guy music stores
used to have a guy you heard a song on
the radio and didn't know who sang it
because used to be they play a couple
songs you have to wait for the DJ to
tell you who it was right so if you
heard a song a bunch times you'd go into
whatever tower you go no ameba you would
go into I would go into the Wiz and
you'd have to sing it for them are there
guys out there right now that are the
guys that any idiot could go in and like
hum a song too and could say I know who
that is and find the record in a record
store finding one of those I mean yeah
if you go to amoeba yeah and you're just
like know what I like the amoeba or
whatever whatever but you're Dave but
that's what we had to do and we would go
to the Wiz and there was a guy that you
could shittily hum any song and you can
tell you who it was yeah the Wiz I feel
like there was one in Shirlington too
but I don't know Jo's music paradise we
always went the camp mill I remember
Kent Mills had a camp mill and then I
worked at our downs that's right I think
I knew that and that's gone um yeah you
know record stores were so much fun
not long ago I took my daughter Violet
because she's starting to get into punk
rock mm-hmm it's funny she's trying to
turn me on to the misfits now because I
was never a misfits guy so she's like
dad come on it's cool I'm like okay but
I took her to like a punk rock record
store on Melrose and it's like she knows
what to do but she was just like she was
blushing she was so psyched to be on the
record still when you all can do record
stories it's just chaos no huh
they don't go nuts no they hump me songs
and I'm like oh yeah that's the misfits
or whatever no no it's fine like people
of course not like if you work at a
record store the last thing you want to
do is recognize a musician yeah you know
oh so they try to play a cool kind of
it's fine yeah but but watching her in a
record store
it was so fucking cool and I was trying
to like tell her like oh this bands cold
try this banded she doesn't want any of
it bad Marines she doesn't but it's you
know I feel like amoebas gonna close oh
that's gonna be a dark day there's a
couple good ones on Ventura Boulevard -
oh yeah mm-hmm
there's one that's near I've even two
cc's no I just moved here oh dude yeah
there's so right here I'm worried
because I feel like it is so hard to
discover cool new music now because the
algorithm culture it's like I literally
when I go on like a news website and I'm
next to someone on the same news website
we get different news based on what
we've googled right right so our
algorithm is changing the kind of things
that we learn and accidentally stumble
upon and when I go and like Spotify I
don't even know I like they decide that
one's funny what after it was either
after Sound City the documentary I made
or the sonic highways serious that I did
for HBO but I was so like I was like I'm
gonna start my own music Network yeah
Channel and I spazzed and was like I
started meeting with people yeah and I'm
like I want a channel like I want to
start my own MTV like an entire 24-hour
channel of just music music music and
programming so I was talking to a bunch
of people about doing it till finally
someone was like do you really want to
be a TV but one of the things that I
loved about the idea which is kind of I
don't know if there's one now just on
television mm-hmm is that you're right
basically when people are searching for
something they kind of they usually only
find what they're looking for or
something similar rather than just sort
of like sitting down and have someone
else curate yeah a playlist or an
experience for them and that's where you
I feel like that's where real discovery
happens so if there was something where
there was a half an hour show that was
about wrapped right and then there was a
half an hour show that was about rock
music and then a half so that you know
you would almost just like turn it on
and leave it on so that and I don't mean
to watch
television all day long but you know to
to curate an experience that's more
diverse than having someone just search
what they're looking for and then have
it based on the algorithms which I don't
even know that word means that means you
get more of the thing you already
googled actually thank you I mean like
I'm very alarmed like my you know I have
dogs and rescue dogs and shit so it's
like all my news is like dog rescue
things and I'm like am I not getting
news because you guys are just marketing
me things that I already know about and
like yeah how am I gonna stumble upon
new bands how am I gonna find out about
this shit yeah I mean I also feel like
it's important for people to go out and
experience war because that's where
that's where the fire really gets lit
when you go like a lot of a lot of
festivals that have really crazy diverse
lineups are super fun yeah you know
European festivals or maybe or something
like Bonnaroo might be the same thing
but when you go to somewhere for eight
or ten hours and you see everyone from
Billy Eilish to Slayer to Anderson Park
to you know a contiguous era or whatever
you have all of those things in one day
I don't know it just sort of like opens
you up a little more so you're more
receptive to the diversity of music
rather than just going to like the
Electric Daisy Carnival right that's all
you get
but I do feel like it's important for
people to go out and see music then live
music is a part of people's lives I've
always thought that that's one of the
problems it's better now but years ago
you know we would go I mean for 30 years
I've been traveling around playing music
and in Europe they had these gigantic
music festivals in every country in
almost every city all throughout the
summer and there's fucking 50,000 people
at each one because it because it's it's
it's more of a part of life and music is
it's kind of more a part of general
consciousness I was just talking about
this at that citilab thing I did another
day
where
the more that you promote music and the
more that you make it a part of people's
lives there's more joy and there's
there's there's something beautiful
about having music in your life every
day but it also it's it's inspiring for
people to go out and see musicians
actually playing on a stage I say the
same with comedy you got to see it live
that was what when Adele started getting
huge everyone was like she could really
sing yeah and I'm like finally there's
someone that can really fuckin say
really like she can't really sing she's
fuckin amazing but it was to me it was
like wait a minute
yeah it's that like is it just because
she can sing and no one else can because
everyone's being auto-tune died or that
you have to go live to make sure that
people are like with you when you're in
when you see someone that's just kicking
ass yeah someone that can fuckin lay it
down for real it's moving yeah you know
and it's really inspiring like oh god
life is worth living and human beings
are real this is great a high I mean
it's a I when I would go see shows as a
kid I would you would get high off of
music yes going to see live shows
attracts I didn't know what that you
know everybody knew what they're like
twice I went there I was like fuck that
I went there many times what would you
do there it was raves I went to a lot of
rage
I was a rave kid okay can I ask you
questions about drug use sure okay did
you dress I don't do drugs I didn't do a
lot of drugs but I did start early the
drugs that I did do so in DC I really I
know the show I probably did it what is
it Love Boat was like really
specifically Washington DC oh shit
love boat was PCP in the mid 80s
like what Marion Barry did no he smoked
crack okay and they elected him again
that's right yeah no you love someone if
you didn't we catch him with hookers too
and
well it was a hooker and some handsome
crack they go well together just always
that's a good pairing do you want to
fucking party so yeah so no Love Boat
was PCP or something like that yeah I
never smoked justing yeah when you
fucking burned it yeah burned white-hot
like an electrical fire and it smelled
like fish this fucking disgusting
there's funny because the first time I
ever met Chappell okay he grew up in DC
yeah right yeah and so it was at this
awards thing and he was at the table and
this is right around the time that his
show I think he was getting an award for
baby the first season okay
and and so we started talking and I said
I said where do you live
and he said oh I live in Ohio but I grew
up in DC I'm like dude I was born in
Ohio and I I moved out of DC and and I
said you from DC goes yeah and I said
you fucking smoke Love Boat didn't you
it was like hell smoke boat I did not
smoke boat I'm like you too much because
most people did yeah like I'm all my
friends did if someone smoked boat in
your bong yeah just throw fish anyway so
we're talking about drugs
so the rave thing so you're like early
90s rave I would go to we would be in
like like parking lots it was a lot of
parking lots you do the thing where you
went to the record store they're like
here's the map there's a lot of that
there was a lot of like people wearing
CDs as necklaces there was a lot of
member that brand tiptoe no there was a
pants by this brand called tiptoe we'd
wear really really big pants and little
tiny crop tops a little tiny top and
then those rings are wandering I had no
fucking tongue
there's a couple years word that it was
kind of the blackout years where I have
no proof of what exactly happened a
recollection but we would go to
commander salamander which was a place
on Wisconsin Avenue across from the ways
of the time and we would get Urban Decay
glitter and we'd put like green glitter
all around we'd shaved the back of our
heads just to here and then do a
ponytail so the back of our heads were
shaved and there's a seed I know I need
to get some pictures of this yeah shit
I'll get them and then on that thing
they're not on that pic they're not on
there no they're not gonna be in my
Google results for sure Zeenat you know
me my house to get food you truly can't
really can't can't even figure out how
to ask you to do it now you sorta I
thank God for door - otherwise I would
starve to death because I cannot leave
my house to get food and even if I
wanted to I'd be in flannel dog pajamas
and I can't be seen that way because I'm
a fashion icon yeah no one deserves that
thankfully connects you to your favorite
restaurants in your city ordering is
easy you open the door - app you choose
what you want to eat and your food will
be delivered to you wherever you are
like you're a goddamn queen makes me
feel like royalty you can't do it you
ain't gonna use door - no you can't get
food yourself
thank God lose that to you not only is
your favorite pizza joint already on
door - but there are over 340 thousand
restaurants in 3300 cities did you know
there was that many cities I knew that
many restaurants with door-to-door
delivery in all 50 states and canada
order from your local go to s or choose
from your favorite national restaurants
what's your favorite national restaurant
if you're at national restaurant the
Cheesecake Factory
because what don't they have really it
literally it takes me an hour and a half
to go through the menu they have it all
and you can get at door - to you right
now our listeners can get five dollars
off the first order of $15 or more when
you download the door - app and enter
promo code Whitney that's my name that's
five dollars off your first order when
you download the door - app from the app
store and enter promo code Whitney don't
forget it
that's promo code Whitney for five
dollars off your first order from door -
you're welcome the holiday rush is come
in it's undeniable if you sell yourself
online you better get ready right now
with shipstation with more people buying
online than ever before yeah that's
really talking about you you have to be
able to help ship orders out quickly
efficiently and affordably but how do
you keep track of all those orders or
decide which shipping carrier to use or
if you're getting the best rates I'll
tell you what ship station can help with
just a few clicks you'll be managing
orders printing labels and getting those
products out the door delivered in time
for the holidays and I know this because
I just started a merch store and my
merchandise is gonna be on ship station
you sure did
what a coincidence we're gonna have lots
of hoodies with Benton's face on it
thank God my mom will have some to wear
no matter where you're selling it's
Amazon Etsy I have some people on Etsy
that needs a use ship station a little
more effectively because they don't get
them and it takes four months to frickin
get them so I'm gonna start setting
passive-aggressive DMS with this ship
station adding it to the people that
sell me these shirts ship station comm
brings you all your orders into one
simple interface making them really easy
to manage from any device even from your
cell phone they offer discounts I'm here
for that yeah no wonder ship station is
a number one choice for online sellers
you'll ship more in less time with the
best rates available I'm talking to you
vintage t-shirt guy who never gets me my
freaking shirts on time take the hassle
out of the holiday shipping this year
led ship station help you handle it all
with ease use my offer code Whitney to
get a 60 day free trial that's two
months free no hassle stress-free
holiday shipping ship station com click
on the microphone at the top of the page
type in Whitney that's my name and to
the offer code Whitney ship station make
ship happen I love that I love that but
I still haven't figured out of sleep
maybe I need to get on dude that
actually kind of works it kind of does I
was listening to some yes DMR AMD AMD
what is it funk I'm just like Singh I
don't know how to say yes ASMR I guess
see if we can try to get Dave Grohl to
fall asleep
okay now kinda end of it no thanks I
don't know I have a big question for you
what about music right now okay cuz I
knew nothing about it what a wine right
now well my big question is does music
in the same way that comedy in movies is
it impact of what's going on with this
political climate like they say that
movies the more zombie movies there are
there more that it's tapping into our
fear of homelessness and poor people
just remember all of the movies in the
80s about like killer nannies remember
nannies used to like you know yeah the
hand that rocks the cradle and all that
shit and all those to me more movies
where she was like fucking everyone at
the office and ruin and it was like our
fear of women entering the workplace
right and not being home all the time
like comedy I know exactly what's going
on with comedy right now in terms of
like the pendulum swinging with being so
afraid of boat culture or being so
afraid of getting cancelled yeah
is that happening in music I don't know
because I don't pay enough attention to
like what's going on in modern popular
music yeah but you're right things are
cyclical I feel like I mean you know how
the music industry sort of works I the
music industry from what I understand
changes every day okay I'll give you a
good example a long time ago there was a
website that was called I think it was
called hit song science.com and there
were these mathematicians that came up
with a mathematical formula to determine
whether your song was going to be a hit
whoa whoa so they would assign it a
formula based on its tempo and time and
key and whatever so so your song would
have like basically a number right and
then they would throw it into their
system and it would it would come out
the readout almost look like stars in
the night sky so each song is like a
little star so you're looking at this
readout and there's like stars
everywhere but there's these clusters of
stars that almost look like little
galaxies and so those were I think they
call them like hit hit clusters or
something if your song fell into one of
those clusters
then more likely than not it would
become a hit well the only reason being
is because it shared the same formula as
a lot of other songs so what that means
is when something becomes popular you
wind up getting a lot of stuff that
sounds just like it coming behind it
because because that's what's popular at
the moment so it could be a tempo that's
the thing that drives me crazy about
popular music is that once someone gets
like a song that's got like a beat then
all sudden that's everything like if I
have to hear that for every song for the
last three fucking here yeah as a
drummer I'm like it's fucking it's like
no but it's like you know there's
there's just more out there than that so
I think what happens when something
becomes popular I don't know if you
consider it relevant but then everything
sort of gravitates towards that and
basically that that just determines or
dictates or you know influences
everything around it just because the
music industry they just sell records
yeah they just want your song on the
radio they just want to make money from
publishing they want to shit like that
so you know it's the stuff that's kind
of off the beaten path that I get into
and I think that those sort of things
might be a little more influenced or
inspired by life rather than just like
an industry thing like a good example is
Billy Eilish and I've talked about her a
million times because my daughter is
obsessed with her I mean the thing that
I think is so exciting about that her
explosion and in in popular music is
that it was based on something real and
that real thing was the connection that
she had with people like my daughter
and so her lyrics are are real and heavy
and dark and very emotion
so and so but my kids not gonna get that
if they turn on a fucking car DB song
I'm sorry but it's just not the way it
is
I mean cardi B's awesome and fun to
dance around too but if you're looking
for a real like deep emotional
connection it's you know Billie Eilish
really has that yeah and those are the
things that really kind of spawn
revolutions like musical revolutions
because it has less to do with the radio
or the industry and stuff has more to do
with a real connection with listeners
what Billie Eilish have happened without
YouTube could she have well that's a
good question yes did you hear that it's
it's debatable mm-hmm I think that would
they go we need you in a crop top and we
need you in a miniskirt and we need you
you know yeah no you just say fuck you
there's no way but you know I think that
the there's this there's this like new
model of independent distribution which
is SoundCloud and shit like yeah which
is great like a lot of the stuff that I
listen to I listen to because of my 13
year old daughter who's super fucking
hip and she finds a lot of stuff on
soundcloud so that's where she found
Billie Eilish a year and a half or two
years ago she played it for me on my
cruises how would you find that she so
and she herself puts her own music on
soundcloud daughters so she'll record in
her bedroom engineered herself mix it
down
you know upload it to an mp3 thing or
whatever and put it up on soundcloud and
it's like that's what you do and I think
that's really inspiring because it's
basically you know a much more
streamlined version of what we were
doing when we were kids
and that you just there's no there's
nothing between you and the listener
it's okay I've got a song and then you
go make a little record and then you
sell it out of your car or whatever you
know zipping cuz there used to be a lot
of gatekeepers and music right there
used to be like 15 old dudes that had to
say yes you can do this yes and so if
you're lucky you can get around that
avoid that and that's where I think
that's where I think the real shit
happens and you know I still believe in
the idea that that you can write and
record songs in your bedroom that and
then go out and perform them on stage in
front of people and the more you do that
the more people will show up and if it's
really great people start to listen and
I mean I remember like Alabama Shakes
like watching that band like go from I
would see their name on the bill like it
1 o'clock in the afternoon on a side
stage of the festival and then two years
later we'd be back at that festival
maybe headline in the side and then two
years later to be back at that festival
and they're you know and they're right
before us or something and then two
years later we're in the same category
at the Grammys and they win the fucking
Best Rock song but it's it's cuz they
fucking did the work and I think it's
really important that's what I mean
that's what happens in comedy which is
sort of like can you get famous at 21
from YouTube yes should you maybe not I
wouldn't want anyone to see any of my
comedy from when I was 20 well I saw you
do stand-up once when uh about seven or
eight years ago
oh god I was at my cousin was doing
stand-up the same night you know it
seems Tim Hamlin and he was doing stuff
it was at The Comedy Store really and I
think you just kind of popped in and did
a little thing I was like working on new
shit just bomb it was fucking hilarious
I think the thing about like dude
midgets have night vision Google thing I
think I was practicing like a late night
setters it was really funny oh god
thanks but I do think though putting
yourself on YouTube of 21 cool if you're
a comic that's great but do you really
want something up from when you were 21
you know like it takes a couple years to
just fucking get good and know who you
are
well this goes back to the conversation
about kids having their own the
Instagram piece because like you know
you have to live with the consequence of
what winds up in the fucking inner
sphere I'm terrified I'm literally
terrified of having kids because of this
shit yeah
yeah but oh there's lots of other
reasons to be terrified they get hurt
kids get hurt yeah don't you worry about
that every fucking minute all day oh
yeah
I will never relax again just constant
that whack them all it's a million
things in my life I won't ever house my
way leg it's good a lot of people have
questions I did a do you have questions
for Dave girl on my Instagram and I got
and a lot of people from Des Moines want
to know how your laryngitis is how am i
Oh cuz I had that yeah well you know I
used to smoke yeah and I stopped smoking
it's hard uh well I stopped smoke I had
another injury mm-hmm where I tore my I
fell off stage again sorry I'm not
laughing at that anyway I had to have
surgery on my arm oh yeah
this is right after my birthday and and
I thought okay you know what
when I'm done with the surgery thing I'm
just gonna stop smoking I've had a
couple cigarettes since then but like
but that was that I was losing my voice
a lot because I was smoking so much and
I kidding
yeah well screaming for three hours a
night that's real do you have like a
voice thing like coach and the whole
thing no because you're supposed to take
care of your vocal cords I got those
nodes you're fucked right yeah I don't
have them really yeah I go to my guy and
he's like you you're lucky no different
guy Joe did you do patches the patch
charts
really you could just stop really yeah
back like did you smoke ever no I didn't
smoke I did vape weed a little bit a
year ago and I got bronchitis and I was
like this isn't right
and I was unfocused for on the tour
Buffalo sorry about those shows I was on
vocal rest for like six months
Wow so I shit the bed in Des Moines huh
no everyone was yeah no no no you want
me to read the questions people were
like he drummed in Des Moines and I
cried he wasn't able to sing but he was
able to drum and tell him saying oh
actually we know there's one of the
great things about the Foo Fighters is
that our drummer Taylor has beautiful
voice is a great singer has own band
where he plays drums and sings at the
same time so if my voice is gone
I just turned him and I go dude just
sing under everything I'm singing
tonight and he'll sing every word of the
hole he'll save my ass no people were
actually I don't know if this is good
news or bad news people were like really
thrilled that you drummed instead right
and many people said they cried that's
weird
a lot of people have questions about
your hair also okay you are an
aberration in my opinion thanks you're
what I haven't told you why I I remember
meeting you and going oh shit I have no
excuse to be emotionally fucked up
because I had this narrative in my head
that was like in order to be a great
artist you have to be a little bit
fucked up or broken or maladaptive and
then you ruin that sorry because I know
you owe me an apology
because you are so everyone's like how
is he so like normal and humble well
okay first of all I'm I think just as
fucked up as everybody else yeah but um
no I mean I honestly think that and I'd
hate to keep coming back to the DC
fridge anything but growing up in
Virginia and Washington DC and playing
music there when I was a kid I don't
really know if anybody had like career
aspiration well you know when you're 14
or 15 years old playing like hardcore
punk rock in this little music scene and
there's like little clubs and it's the
same hundred people at every show and
you're going to see your favorite bands
and your friends are in your favorite
band it was just so far outside of like
trying to become a fucking
world-renowned rock legend yeah it's
just like oh yeah I just want to fucking
play music I knew I wasn't gonna go to
college I just was I was a terrible
student I didn't finish high school I
worked at a Furniture Warehouse and
worked other jobs and stuff like that
and I just sort of thought you know I
just want to play music and work and
have an apartment and do that it's a
very juvenile way to look at life but at
the time it was like I didn't think that
I could be go
so that's really where I fell in love
with playing music and I still feel that
way so any of the like crazy reward that
I've had over the last 25 years
I mean it's strange to me like it is it
is weird to me that you know I joined a
band and then the band became fucking
gigantic and it just didn't compute it
didn't make sense because I didn't
necessarily feel like I was doing
anything differently that I've ever done
I just happened to be in a band with the
greatest fucking songwriter ever and
then those songs became huge and you
know if I ever felt overwhelmed I'd just
go back to Virginia my mom's house in
Springfield and like hang out with my
friends ride motorcycles and barbecue
and then you know then I'd go back to
being a Nirvana and then I'd go back to
DC and so I don't really see what the
big deal is like I don't understand why
I don't understand why something like
that I mean I can't even say that
because I do understand why some people
have a hard time with it but for me
personally it it made my life a little
more complicated but I do believe that
it made my life better like I got I
helped my mother retire from being a
schoolteacher I helped my mother buy a
house
i I I bought my own house I bought a
truck
I built a studio in the basement I
started another band and started my own
record label and my band is on my label
and I get to license and distribute all
the Foo Fighters stuff to to another
company so we're in control of
everything we do it's like it a lot of
it seems really ideal there's downsides
to everything and yeah at times it's
really difficult but I mean I look at I
look at what I could have been doing and
I think I'd rather do this than what I
then you know like drywall the fucking
new Starbucks on seventh and eighth my
enemy right and so yeah so and plus it's
just you know it's nice to be nice to
people and people
[Music]
you know usually nice to me I don't get
like screaming crazy crying fans I just
get people like yo Dave what's up I'm
like hey that's gone that's cool that's
cool that your fans are cool that says a
lot we have cool fans that says a lot
my anyone that comes up to me is very
bossy and I people I mean you people ask
you for photos or do they not oh yeah
all day long I had people to come up to
me and they'll be like hey my phone's
dead could you take a photo on your
camera and just email it to me that's
not what am i giving it happens to be
all the time that all the time and then
I be able to come up to me I have a lot
of dudes that come up to me on the bike
hey I don't know who you are my
girlfriend loves you well that's okay
dude why do you need to hurt my female
and do it okay I know it happens I don't
know who the fuck my kids like and then
they go I'm sorry I don't know who you
are and then you say like that's good it
makes my life a lot easier either types
we're even yeah it could be worse that
honestly is my life motto it could be
worse Wow that you have like and I'll
say that in Teleca it's really really
worse and then I'll be like yeah it
could be a lot worse do you think though
and now in music that there's I know in
comedy enough bad things have happened
that less people are definitely having
less maladaptive behaviors and choices
most people I know in comedy they're
sober they're vegan they're drinking
Jamba Juice doing really yoga yeah it's
a bunch of dorks Sam Kinison yeah and I
mean depression is still prevalent it's
very and you know it's but it seems like
everyone's getting ahead of it everyone
I know has a therapist in comedy you
know it's interesting because I didn't
talk to dr. drew about this but
something similar is fucking ages ago
ten years ago or more but I think your
therapist
no I was doing a fucking sexy show
whatever that was
fifteen years ago there's a long time
ago but at the time he was sort of doing
a study with entertainers to determine I
guess to sort of figure out what type of
person becomes an entertainer I think
it's the same a lot of musicians and a
lot of entertainers I think that maybe
their their motivation comes from a
place where there is a lot of emptiness
and they seem you know they feel the
need to kind of I don't know do whatever
they do in order to repair that love at
all costs yeah yes so yeah so it's
similar well I do think music at least
bands and stand-ups are slightly
different cuz stand-ups are like I'm
gonna do this alone you know I don't
know how you do that he isolated it's
not it's not healthy that's weird very
it's not why did you decide to do that
bad childhood all the horrible things
that went down in Rehoboth Beach
Maryland I think there I think there is
when I grew up I'll speak for myself I
grew up around a lot of mental illness a
lot of addiction a lot of alcoholism and
the safest place was in my room alone
making fake music videos listening to my
brother's go-go tapes that's where I
felt the safest when I had you was away
from the drinking and the that shit so I
do think that comedians are slightly
different than musicians in that way is
that people are scary to us team we
don't I used to do that's sort of weird
what I don't know if I want to tell
everybody this you can always cut it out
later I used to I used to
I had this tape recorder mm-hmm little
cassette recorder and I would listen to
music before I went to bed and then when
I was maybe like 13 12 or 13 I would hit
record and I would talk about my
problems
Oh for like the whole side of a tape and
then I would rewind it and listen back
and fall asleep listening to myself
talking about my problems when's last
time you did that I was 13 it's not
weird that's kind of like a genius
therapy I don't know why I did it well I
dunno it's taken me a long time to learn
now the therapist that I work
explain as soon as you say one of your
fears out loud
it engages your frontal lobe they're
inherently less afraid uh you just go
I'm afraid of interviewing Dave Grohl
today
I'm nervous about interviewing Dave
Grohl I'll be less than or risk is my
frontal lobe will get engaged see it
works and then you stop producing
cortisol and adrenaline so you must have
known that in an early age no I had no
fun talking about your divorce we can
put those on eBay and raise a lot of
money mm-hmm where the firefighters
pretty big barbecue remix I I do think
though comics don't play well with
others the same way you can in a band
and I remember when I would tour and do
radio because I just have to do radio
you know we're like before there was
YouTube and Instagram and that shit you
would do radio to remember this Mancow
in Chicago remember no you probably were
too big to ever have to go on he was
kind of like a the stern of Chicago
something and I'd go on and there'd be
bands there it'd be like 6 a.m. and I'd
be like god damn that looks so much more
fun than this to be like rolling with
five people and like you know there is
something cool about playing music with
other people that you might not
necessarily know or be able to talk to
or you know I've been in bands where
like the relationship is so
dysfunctional yeah till we put on the
instruments Wow and it's the fucking
greatest thing in the world because in a
way and it depends on what kind of music
you're playing but you do communicate
musically with each other and so
sometimes you connect with the musician
musically more so than you would
personally yeah and and then do you just
know like have boundaries in terms of
like okay this is how much time to spend
with this bird it's so fucked up because
it's almost like SNM there's a lot of
trust involved no you know it has a lot
to do
with like my friend Josh mommy who's in
Queens of the Stone Age when we play
together
it's like instantly great when he's on
guitar and I'm on the drums we totally
finish each other's sandwiches we just
fucking we completely just have this
thing where we can do it and it's fun
because we sort of like push and pull
each other in this way way that it's
like a conversation but but a lot louder
I don't know it's probably find someone
that you can really jam with like that
like Taylor and I my drummer Taylor and
I I mean we're in chemistry is that
we're like yeah I mean to me and this is
there's nothing before the Foo Fighters
go on stage there's no like to God
please give me the strength there's no
bones
well we drink a lot of and but to me the
most important thing is that we're
laughing hysterically as we walk on
stage and every night we have those 15
minutes 20 half an hour before going on
and for real it is we are usually
fucking cracking up right as we walk
onstage and so that's how you begin the
show and then there's you know and it's
amazing I don't know how these bands
that don't get along do it I wouldn't
saw the Eagles when they were at the
forum I don't know why I don't know why
and they all came on stage at different
times they wouldn't even speak to each
other I mean so they're also in shorts
which is another conversation but they
would they were in shorts in pyjamas oh
it's short they were barely there but
they all came in at important to feel
comfortable onstage I was like oh like
they're doing this dramatic thing where
they're coming out one at a time could
you still have the same kind of musical
chemistry and not speak at all offstage
or is it like you know makeup sex
well yeah I think that when you're with
it's a it's it's I've been in bands
where there's not a lot of communication
and then you go on stage no because I
honestly feel like the emotional
connection that you have with the person
influences what happens on stage or off
but when you're like jamming in front of
a bunch of people I don't know maybe
it's just me but I like to feel
like I'm with my fucking gang yeah and
because when there's a hundred thousand
people there it's like you don't want
your fucking cheese in the wind you
don't want to stand there like you're
like oh my god it's just me and a
fucking people I don't know you know
it's like if it's us then I feel a
little bit more level do you think that
like there's something I know this
definitely happens in comedy I think
it's having a little bit less now
because I think fan bases are just more
fragmented or there's less of like
everyone knows one comedian you know but
do you think that they're I feel like
Foo Fighters and obviously all the bands
you've been in you can get really really
famous and still be cool whereas we're
not cool
I disagree now we're not I don't know if
you are willing you're allowed well
here's the thing
so no I know there's like we are deaf
I've done interviews with people before
where they basically say like what does
it feel like to play music that's
obsolete I've had that like I've had
journalists I had a guy in London that
worked for lunch that's a dick of a
person I was kind of pissed but no we're
wild we just sold out two nights at
Wembley - I was a fuckhead he was a dick
anyway well that's not true that
person's not that is a dumb person well
I think a lot of people I mean look at
this point you know the whole dad rock
thing we're totally we're so dad I know
15 year olds that are obsessed with your
music we're totally I mean as which is
we got that interview and you're not
you're actually I know you see the guy
though so we were like in Singapore or
something there are young people on it
and now I feel the name yeah we were in
Singapore on this promo tour for the
last record and this and this woman
interview first question she's like so
what's it like to be a dad rock band no
first of all we are all dads and you're
right we're a rock band I don't like
that one bit but here's the thing is
that I think that you know at this point
look
I'm 50 years old I fucking gray hair I'm
fucking right now I need to show you I
don't want to I don't validate so I have
never but you know the funny thing is I
have never considered our band cool and
I like that because why your cool
problem we've sorted that's the coolest
thing ever I know 9 levels irony meta
but yeah I think that we there was a
time I remember like I ran to learn to
fly video and stuff like that we were
basically trying to make an am gold
record but this is 1998 and I had a
house outside of Alexandria Virginia it
was in alexander's that's out of Old
Town and I built this studio in my
basement and all I was listening to was
like Andrew gold and Gerry Rafferty and
10cc and just full-on a.m. call because
at that that era of music it was purely
based on melody and harmony it was
really musical period for music I loved
it and that's why I grew up listening
like Helen Reddy and Phoebe's no shit
like that like I loved music like that
Carly Simon and that was the shit my mom
and I would listen to in her Ford
Maverick car so at the time this is 1998
music was like getting really like it
was like new metal yeah is a huge thing
rap metal a new metal and stuff I hope
that's how you dance just like this and
so I'm like a scarecrow and so so I was
like well fuck man let's make an am gold
record and really honestly we were so
not we've just never been hip or cool we
just really haven't and I think I think
that the reason why we're still here is
because we do kind of disconnect
ourselves from like the popular stuff
that's going on but also because what
the fuck do we care
like honestly you know I just want to
fucking play music you know and and
having watched a lot of my friends not
survive I'm just like I just wanted to
play I just want to like be alive and
play music and I really don't give a
fuck like
we're cool or not so I don't want to
argue with you but you're very cool but
you're humble and that's why you're not
gonna go insane
so it's good to be humble and cool won't
argue with you the end and I have
questions for you about music videos now
okay pop-up video I miss it I do too
I miss it why did that go away because
music think about it if you were to do
pop-up I wanted to bring pop a video
back I can ask doc Herzog about it but
would pop a video now just be like boom
this was CGI boom we did the screen yeah
why doesn't that to meet music videos
were my life watching them over and over
again pop-up video I live for it
I remember when someone at MTV telling
me that this is fucking a long time ago
25 years ago that the criteria of videos
that they would program basically like
the thing was they wanted if you they
wanted the viewer to want to be in the
band or in the video so as a viewer if
you were watching something like you
know like fuck like 180 to like the
learjet and they're really fun with
those guys or whatever that that was
something it's probably still a lot of
the you know a lot of the motivation
behind making music video just you know
it's it's kind of it shows you a charmed
more beautiful rose colored version of
am i making sense right now yeah so I
think so I'm sweating
why oh god you're hot okay I'm not
letting you go yet we're gonna do a
quick first did you do anything for
Halloween uh yeah check retreated yeah
yeah did you have a costume yeah but it
was lame
really it was like this fucking trench
coat and put on a skull mask oh it was
actually so why do you have so many
trench coats we live in LA but yeah I
know
yeah and it's gold masks and and what
now well that's another thing is like
I'm walking around the neighborhood and
I think kids are scared of me
and their parents are pissed oh because
I'm scary like people your school mascot
what the skull mask what how they're
maybe even without it but like with the
skull mask yes yeah were there a lot of
trick-or-treaters in your neighborhood
we weren't in my neighborhood but yes
there were a ton of trick-or-treaters
okay I'm gonna do little speed round
okay um have you ever made a mistake and
then later realized it was not a mistake
because I'm obsessed with yes musically
oh absolutely you record something like
uh I've got I fucked that up so bad and
then like no no keep it and it because
that's the best part of the song I love
that so much and do you have songs like
come to you and then you're like fuck I
have the song I'm I had I have to go do
it
like that's how sorry I think is that
Cemal isn't that like the famous Mitch
Hedberg bit where he talks about like
the funniest
he's got the funniest joke in the world
in mind but the pen and paper is so far
away I started stand-up after Mitch and
discovered him kind of after and I'm so
glad I discovered him after I started
doing stand-up because if I had seen his
work before I probably wouldn't have
done it I would've been too intimidated
he's funny went to Target I missed my
favorite joke to have any pet peeves uh
yeah
oh god what are some besides people that
are like I don't know you know what's a
pet peeve of mine I get really I notice
weird little things with people that I
can't unnotice like me what now things
like the sound it's usually sound
actually really a lot of chewing do you
think you have that misophonia thing I
have that apparently I don't know if
that is which is when things are just
louder - you know I'm deaf as a fucking
post really but it doesn't play music oh
yeah but before that I can hear voices
from across the room I can hear really I
I one time went into a building and I
heard like a humming sound there's
certain people that can hear certain
waves or something and it was the alarm
and it was so loud to me I couldn't even
focus but nobody else heard it yeah I'm
a nightmare yeah I think it's mostly
like chewing sounds the chilling thing
when I ask people if they're showing gum
in front of me like to stop could you
not how do I have other you might have
misophonia
afonya or synesthesia is that when you
hear in color it's when you see music
it's kind of when your wires across I do
have that because I don't read music but
I can hear a song and uh I imagine the
arrangement like in shapes in my head oh
well so well so I can memorize
arrangements really easily in parts
because I kind of see them that's wild
is that called synesthesia I don't know
what that is it's genius madman I
wouldn't call it that either I don't
know what it is I think it's uh I think
it's just a drummer that does not read
music
yeah do you I'm really big about talking
about gifts cuz I like giving gifts
what's the best gift you've ever gotten
or a good one the best gift ever
what do you get Dave Grohl and I'm big
on how to shop for dad's like what to
get it you know what a good one is tell
me the Japanese toilet whoa like the ass
blasting fucking Oh with the bidet the
day whoa whoa you want to get a it's not
really a guy thing I don't I don't I
think it is let me tell you I got one
mm-hmm GameChanger I just shit in it I
don't use the other stuff I don't know
it's got like a big control panel it
doesn't it put water up on your tush if
you ask but like you can like make it
like oscillate
really yeah water pressure Add to Cart
yeah you could do that
I don't know that yeah how many times a
day you using this thing to shit once a
day I think yours was doing more than
that no you're not yes I think you are
are you I think so okay maybe I do shit
we did we had hope you had talked about
your Viper intake how do you take care
of your mental health music really does
help yeah it really does writing helps a
lot yeah what do you write on I write on
paper pen and paper yeah are you fuck
happen to you I'm from the future
I usually write in Microsoft Word I
wouldn't even know how to open that
program you don't I am so I'm practical
Amish like a Luddite I can't I just
don't write I can run I can engineer
like a recording session yep
and Pro Tools do all the things
gradually I'm all good with that but
when it comes to any other level of
computer savvy I just can't I think it
loses some soul and emotion when you're
on a computer yeah I mean it's yeah it's
weird though the other day I actually
did type something out on my phone but I
also have like little phone notes yeah
this is what it sounds like ding ding
ding ding ding oh this is what it sounds
like when you come up with ideas for
songs and you're just humming them oh
and your voice no my voice notes oh my
gosh I don't hold on let's see what we
got
dave grohl voice no so there's that's
this is there's a hundred and twenty of
these I have them and I'm too
embarrassed to play them for you cuz
mine are like jokes mine are like I have
a black hair growing out of my chin
insert joke here wait really
I just put like like premises down what
are they and then you go into the studio
with it oh there's actually some
instruments
[Music]
if I come up with an idea
so you haven't written that down
well I can't write it down mine's too
embarrassing every music mine are like
going on scissor at comedy clubs you
record other people talking really hate
it can't listen back to it then why did
you even record it my biggest nightmare
ever is that I used to have these if you
put them in your iTunes is that even
still a thing is iTunes still a thing I
don't have I don't have
Apple music I don't know how it works
title what are we doing now
there used to be iTunes and your voice
memos would go in with your music
chronic right your music library or
whatever and I remember one night I was
on a date with a guy and we came back to
my house and were hanging out and we
were like maybe gonna make out and it
was on just random what's up with
squirting like it was just something so
embarrassing and I was just like well
there goes that that's that no bigger
game killer than my nasal ass boys
coming on you know what you should how
about you don't listen to yourself why
don't you go like do a show and walk
away thinking I just kicked ass and just
kind of believe that you just kicked ass
not being a shame spiral in the car yeah
I don't know what that would be like
yeah I can't I don't listen to live
recordings in my band I on new shit and
also I think that when you know you're
recording you put too much pressure on
yourself and you're inherently not as
free and it's fun so it's never as good
and then when I don't record I'm like
fuck that was a good show oh right I
shouldn't put myself on her microscope
record and I should be in the goddamn
moment yeah and these are in the cloud
somewhere and someone's gonna hack them
and ruin my career at something and
Jagermeister and Jagger and Jagger what
I'll save Grohl what else do we need to
know this is your fucking shower I don't
know I want to talk to you forever you
done know I've never done I've never
done last question fuck last one
what do you got what do you think I'll
give you two more two more questions you
just keep going what time is it I mean
we'll just out it I'm not where do you
have to be I'm making a fucking record
right now in the grocery store pick up
some batteries yeah just hang out
fucking shopping all day long do a
podcast you do it in your this is wait
we didn't talk about the other podcast
you're on oh you're on the bone Appetit
podcast yes I do have a question are you
scared of anything you strike me as
someone who's quite fearless uh we're
not like I don't like I don't like being
strapped into things yeah
so I cornered on podcast yeah like this
you know like I don't like this I do
yeah I don't mind rollercoasters that's
that's not how am i afraid of nothing
see unbelievable I don't know you're
fearless man I guess no not really
I don't elevators kind of I've been
stuck oh my god there was once where I
got stuck in it it's only happened once
that's my nightmare
mine too always that was the one thing
and it was an ostrich I was in New
Zealand and I was staying in this hotel
I was on the 60th fucking floor like way
up there I was checking out and it was
one of those fancy hotels where you need
the key to get to your room and the
record company had given me a bottle of
wine but they had put like this Foo
Fighters New Zealand label on oh cool
and so I'm like cool and so I get in the
elevator I start coming down it's like
new and we have a show that night coming
down and the elevator just stops on the
30th floor and immediate panic coming
fuck fuck fuck and I'm like sorry hit
lobby lobby lobby nothing happens I hit
open door open door open door holy shit
I am stuck like by myself in an elevator
on the 30th floor right now holy fucking
shit so I hit the little button the call
button and it goes and they're like
friend answered and like hi I'm stuck in
your elevator right now on the 30th
floor and they're like oh my god we're
so sorry we'll be there in a couple
minutes and I'm like fuck and I the
panic hit so hard that all the muscles
on my back just went on and this bottle
of wine had a screw top okay open the
bottle of wine just read chug the bottle
of wine right as I like when the
elevator starts moving so now I'm
hammered at noon
[Music]
sucked the last thing that's so funny to
me the last thing I'm going to say is
not a question it's a thank you actually
I'm gonna end with some kind of an
emotional note I remember reading
somewhere like 10 years ago something
you said something in an interview my
best friend from college is this girl
Lizzie Goodman who wrote that book meet
me in the bathroom
she's like a brilliant music journalist
and she had shown me some article you
were whatever you said something where
you said there's no wrong way to grieve
you said that in something I don't
remember how it kind of stuck with me
yeah and my dad passed a year and a half
ago and I didn't cry for the first
couple days and then I was crying so
hard I couldn't breathe for like four
months
and then I would go numb and then I
would cry and I remember the hardest
part about grieving about it is that I
was beating myself up for not grieving
properly yeah and that kept coming up in
my head you saying there's no wrong way
to grieve and it helped me be gentle
with myself through the grieving process
so I owe you a thank you for that you're
welcome
it's funny I think that yeah yeah it's
weird
my best friend that I grew up with that
I'd moved since I was five years old we
were inseparable like my whole entire
life and he passed away maybe like ten
years ago and he overdose on drugs and
like we were so super tight we had ESP
like we knew each other so well our
entire lives we spent our whole lives
together and that one was really tricky
because I still don't feel like I've
properly agreed it was such like we had
we were so close with each other and we
were such a huge part of each other's
lives that then all of a sudden he's
gone and and it's weird like you you
wait for that release you know you wait
for everything just to come like all
crashing down or for it just to come
pouring out of you and I guess sometimes
it doesn't sometimes it doesn't you know
one really weird thing is that before
Kurt died he he overdosed once when we
were on tour and I was actually back at
home and he was in Europe and someone
had called me and told me that he had
died and I immediately freaked out and
was a total disaster and just crying and
losing my mind
and then five minutes mate later they
called and said actually he's not dead
so then it was the greatest day of my
life because he was okay but I was just
so um I was just so confused like
emotionally I was just like oh my god
what do I even feel right now five
minutes ago I thought that he had died
and now he's alive and that's so weird
and so um so when he finally did pass
away I was I just had such crazy
emotional confusion that it was really
really strange and still to this day I
don't even know if I've figured it out I
mean I it's that that was a long time
ago and I've talked about it and thought
about it and grieved about it a lot but
yeah I don't think that there's any sort
of like roadmap for it I think that each
person does it in a different way and
it's okay to it's just okay if you have
those periods where you feel shame for
not feeling more and and but I don't
necessarily think you should I think it
just is what it is and it'll get I mean
it'll get you eventually it's it's your
body way of probably letting you feel
only as much as you can take yeah you
know I think my body I couldn't believe
how little I was feeling but I think it
was my body's way of doling the pain out
a little bit at a time so that I could
survive it yeah and no one told me about
the anger either no one told me that
rage comes up to and but I did have you
kind of over
in the back of my head of like there's
no wrong way to do this there's no wrong
way to do this you can be nuts you can
be a loner and I also don't want to talk
to anyone I don't want to see anyone
sure and I would have beaten myself up
about that so you kind of stopped me my
inner bully from tearing myself apart
thank you for saying that so I owe you
another coffee or something well that
was really fun until just now
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh my god here we are
dave is gone that was scary scary I was
nervous did I seem nervous no really no
you think - fine
did you like that interview yeah I did I
really like him yeah he's a human angel
he's a he's too good for us he's too
good for the world just a specific weird
trash people and not good enough for
take role I just can't believe he's just
the nicest guy on the planet you're not
arresting also the most talented and
mindful and thoughtful hmm why am I so
surprised when famous people are nice
because I've met so many monsters I
think that's why normally your heroes
are pretty disappointing I don't think
that's true how many of your heroes have
you met one who you
I haven't well I'm gonna I'm probably
disappointed you before just visually
like out set wise he was super
interesting he's so down to earth I feel
like you wore extra makeup today for him
know what I only have on a tinted
moisturizer first of all that's a tinted
moisturizer when I wear every day with
sunscreen is it a tinted sunscreen or a
tinted moisturizer something you put no
it's not the same thing that just when
you buy them all together do you put
sunscreen vent into moisturizer one
thing in case you guys don't know Benton
knows everything in the world about
makeup he used to work at Sephora and
knows about all the shit and he's the
only reason I know anything I heard that
if you put tinted sunscreen on that
causes breakouts and you should do
people how dare you interrupt me in
front of my fans with logic and facts
let me keep rambling and providing
dribble to the messes
I heard you should do sunscreen then
makeup not tinted SPF stuff yeah maybe
you should that's probably true yeah but
I mean most girls that's my brand guys
probably true new name most girls and
guys nowadays are wearing so much makeup
the sun's not penetrating that anyways
okay look but makeup isn't SPF unless it
has SPF in it yeah but most of them
don't anymore because old white women
were highly against it what does that
mean Oh every day they were coming in so
for I'm Billy what makeup does not have
SPF in it why don't they want it they
needed the money once they won't be
today think people think SPF makes you
you can't be tan with it
what you can't write I mean as an old
white woman
you can't an it's protecting you from UV
rays you're not gonna get as hands if
you're buttering up and laying on the
beach but I mean like you're not gonna
be like I mean like we're not
translucent I am and we take for
yourself you're pretty vampire yeah but
I mean okay you know what I'm leaving go
please I dare you to try to man that I
keep with the door security I mean it
just you can still be like keV color
also there's a hundred products that you
can buy attaining with water
what tanning water is like a self-tanner
I don't do self-tanner it never goes
well Joey's hood I always look like I
have a skin disease it looks you at
yourself
yes that's the problem is our
professional okay I don't have that kind
of time what who are you or the
professional I would hire no I don't
like I don't like that because something
it I look very scurvy II the day awesome
the wrong one I didn't say it's like
come on from Dollar General I meant like
get a nice one
it's general dollar first of all second
of all in general no it's not a South in
his dollar general in the known inch it
is generous are dyslexic so one of us in
general I think it's general dollar no
it's not Google it okay well we're our
general
oh we're cutting this out education
Benton being right is not it we should
not set this precedent on this podcast I
thought was fun
I do have questions for you though
because I have noticed a lot of my
straight guy friends and this is not
just an LA thing name um crystal ear a
lot of my straight guy friends I'm
learning are experimenting with makeup
and I'm not even joking these are not
actors these are not even people on
television I've had a couple straight
guy friends just have like what looks
like caulk or like grout and I don't
know what to say cuz obviously it's
becoming more socially acceptable for
straight guys to wear makeup but I feel
like do we call them out when it looks
crazy do i what they say to women are
you tired you're so creative I hate it
when people do that I'm like I got
eight hours of sleep but thanks that's
just my face but let me ask you a
question when you're working Sephora
were straight guys coming in to buy
makeup so straight guys when they come
in they will try to find like I that I
look like this when I work there
so they'll try to find someone that some
people are just like can you find the
way you like I look like a butter turkey
with a beard you ever seen a muffin grow
facial hair that's what I look like
that's a fact blueberry no you look like
the interior designer from Beetlejuice
rude beard
there's a rudest thing I've ever heard
in my life I think it's the number-two
The Trevor Project we're donating we're
donating you don't look like him a lot
of people yeah make it better
Instagram say that you're like remind
them of him I think that's a compliment
okay so anyways what I'm getting at is
though try to find someone they relate
to and they would come up in a whisper
they'd be like what do you have any um
is there anything you hear for guys and
I'd like all of it
what buy something because I have some
straight guy friends who I'll just see
have obviously experimented with like
concealer but no one's told them like
you can't just put on any anything beige
it's not gonna you have to make sure it
matches your skin become a hate crime
very quickly if you don't have the right
shade also we can see it but that would
require talking to someone in admitting
that you wanted to wear it that's true
so we've had this bubble you know I mean
but in the past but you man you've been
in the trenches of this when a man in
your experience straight man is walked
into Sephora
what do they say they will whisper what
they want to you this or they'll have
their girlfriends ask a lot of people do
that they'll have their girlfriend ever
dated has asked to use my makeup I
should probably look into that as soon
as I said that I was like a lot of
things are trying to make sense
they'll have their girlfriend and
they'll have a reason always look I have
a job interview I'm going to this thing
I'm a news anchor like whatever it's
something that they need it for okay
it's for something specific because
every guy I've ever dated when they have
a big zit they're like can you help me
yeah they'll never let you try it on
them which is why it never matches yeah
just guess but don't you can't you
well is it your makeup on your wrist I
don't but this is a question is does
this skin on your wrist for those of you
listening it's like right where you're I
don't know your wrist is is that the
same colors your face no it's the color
of your breasts
I mean that's like a cool I guess it's
like a trick if you want to do that
there's all kinds of tricks but just put
it on just to put put it on your cheek
uh-huh so I mean that's what you should
do but and then they usually don't leave
buying anything I was dating a guy and I
may or may not have been snooping in his
bathroom it's called research it's
called self care it's called trying to
find red flags before you've been in the
relationship for three fucking I it was
a red flag to him that I was snooping
but I was looking for red flags and
they're usually in the bathroom drawers
so I was quietly opening his drawers and
saw some makeup some like covergirl
navier--
he was there yes quietly quiet something
I've been quiet before doesn't happen a
lot but I'm capable of it and I saw it
and the first thing I thought was oh my
god he has a girlfriend right but then I
was like wait a girl wouldn't use a
cover like an old girls know that makeup
expires and I knew the packaging was old
so I was like wait a second is he dating
a girl who has makeup from the 90 like
how old is this his girlfriend like it
was just it didn't really add up and I
end up confronting him about it because
I was worried that you know he lived
with someone or something and he was
like it's mine and I'm it was a lot to
process and I hate that I had a
judgement about it not because I don't
think sure I should be able to wear
makeup it was more like oh is it a red
flag that he's vain or like is he a
narcissist or like does he want to be an
actor was that really a tour was a bit
or was it the masculinity yeah well I
was also more I was like ah it's also a
red flag that he can't be vulnerable and
admit if he wants to wear makeup he
should be able to and he's insecure and
maybe there's some something there
that's a red flag why can't he just go
to Sephora and just say hey I wants to
makeup to cover up my zits well
historically make it was a masculine
thing like Egypt they were to give it's
like a it was for hygiene you know or
that to get keep bugs out if that
eyeliner was to keep bugs out of your
eyes really yeah and then like don't we
all have like a billion bugs in our
eyelashes
I don't know I don't um and you know and
then they have like the Romans ruse
their cheeks they would put you know
rose petals like brothers rose
yeah blood roses whatever you wanna
think enemy and then you know the French
they did like beauty marks and powdered
wigs and Men more high heels and it was
Queen Victoria the first she outlawed
all makeup so no one could wear so only
she could no she didn't wear no one was
allowed to wear it she thought it was
too feminine and she linked femininity
to the devil really and so there was a
big wave or no one could wear makeup it
was like a legal Queen Victoria of
England before the first she did a lot
of fucker queens did a lot of fucked up
shit we forget we talk about like
there's no women in power Queens were in
power and they were savage and then you
know and then you move into the 80s you
have like Bowie and you have like Scott
Barnes is that kind of nineties and then
you have like prints all those people
dabble you make it begin and then guys
like well they're cool so that's cool no
one is router to me in the David Bowie
yeah and then you move into 2000s
there's all the guy line or you know
there's Pete Wentz and there's romance
olivine she had guyliner on I don't know
what that means but you ever see it that
was what does that mean just you're
allowed to say that I am what does that
mean you know like it's like androgynous
OD eyeliner is literally it silent like
guys aware but it's done very late but
here's what I say there's nothing hotter
than a guy that is breaking rules you
know so a guy wearing eyeliner or makeup
you're just like damn that is a
iconoclast that is a badass that doesn't
give a fuck or it could be a red flag it
could go either way
yeah and you know and then Adam Lambert
popped up in the 2000s and he was full
down Mac beat he had on steno
full-coverage makeup and that was the
aim anybody is like well he's so cool I
say everybody lightly but you know most
people yeah and then we had the Jeffrey
star was on MySpace yeah so it's just
I'm talking that straight the
conversation that I'm interested in is
why can't straight man a straight man
walk into a Sephora or wherever and say
I would like some concealer for my
under-eye bags or whatever it is which
Chris D'Elia you should do because we've
only seen so many men wearing makeup
yeah it's connected to femininity yeah
but what I'm interested in is your
experience of having men come in and
like surreptitiously covertly try to get
it and should we have more men's
make it it doesn't have a gender you
not have a gender there's true but
colors unfortunately because of social
construction whatever a lot of guys
probably don't want a big pink bottle on
there what foundation do that comes in a
pink bottle show me one in your bathroom
they are all clear bottle with black
lids what do you need I okay
you brought me purple eyeshadow brushes
and they made me physically ill I'm
always that's the Lakers don't they wear
purple that's a good point that you're
make you're bringing up some good
mountain and frankly it's ego okay this
is that's ego where you are marketing
toward that's the only time someone's
markets towards your ego yeah comes to
men everything else is if you need this
because you're bad so let me ask you can
we do this I think we should do a video
a makeup video for men first on Chris
D'Elia yes we will use Chris D'Elia
and his giant eye bags and we will do
because I think that a lot of these
makeup contouring videos no one is
making stuff for straight men just to go
here's how to just cover a zit
here's how to just pluck your eyebrows
because I'm sick of having to do it for
the guys that I date there was like can
you pluck my eyebrows can you and it's
just like I don't work for you yeah but
also we could avoid ant and I just want
to save you guys some embarrassment
because I'm seeing a lot of guys out
there in the streets with just weird
like dabs of whiteout on their face it
looks crazy because I don't think the
guys necessarily know how to cover red
which of the pimples red correct which
means you have to put a color corrector
okay well now you're pushing it but I'm
missing you what if you want to look
natural and will you do that what can
you do a YouTube video not on me I don't
have under eye bags cuz I have you skin
can you actually really don't know well
I don't work at skin tired quartz guys
either they all the age like the freakin
mother willow from Pocahontas what they
all look like just a dry barky skin and
they're like hey what I think that's
kind of hot though it's unfortunate that
guys the older they get the how do they
look I think you disagree no I mean
that's fine like when guys have like
deep lines and ridges I think it's kind
of hot oh yeah that's different that's
the issues with my dad you have laugh
lines and line
I'm just saying you're skinny you should
be able to peel your skin off on one
layer I think we should do a makeup
tutorial for straight guys the three in
this room especially that is just to
cover zits
if you want guys should be able to wear
MIT cover redness around here so that it
actually looks concealed yeah because I
don't think most guys understand that I
can see if you've applied makeup wrong
women notice you look crazy yeah a lot
of guys are out there in the streets
looking crazy in the streets looking
crazy
yes it looks like a just they'll just
like they'll just put it on some old dry
crusty ass makeup just looks like clam
chowder it's different because men have
thicker skin
I mean metaphorically but I have told
called guys out about it like kindly
I'll pull the guys side and go hey I can
like see you're concealing the booty
talk about concealer look you and then
like we don't talk for six months yeah
they physically have thicker skin like
just on their face and also it grows
hair so there's a lot of different it's
different guys skin is different you can
just put foundation on cuz it'll grab
the texture from your hair fall as long
as Daleks are very different I think we
should do a mini tutorial on pitching
your face the way you do it you post
event to so many times okay I'm not
gonna let it go because I think it's it
looks crazy crazy
it's just how Benten itches his face I
do like this then this look I think it
looks insane no dislike insane to do
this if we were to a dinner party and I
was like yes I love that story oh by the
way if you guys are just listening you
don't know what's happening
Benton's crazy like like tapping his
face like a crazy person having a
seizure just with his Alliant AB it's a
tap so that you don't rip capillaries is
that what it's reason is because you
should never scratch and you should also
never put makeup on going downwards
right look at the poster face down there
elasticity skincare mostly you shouldn't
you shouldn't put on with you don't put
may come off your hands in general I do
I mean you can if you're like I makeup
artist because they know channeling
yeah but no you rub you put makeup on
like this but you just rub both circles
crazy
I do it in circles I'm here liftoff you
put makeup on your whole face and then I
did your left I do I put makeup over my
lips and then I take a towel and then
wipe it off it's how you explore man
doing makeup how dare you I'm triggered
will you tell me the quick story about
when you were working at Sephora and the
women shop lifted lipstick yes we used
to when I worked this was it Mac that's
before because that makes a difference
because the way we just play lipstick so
it Mac if you've ever been into Mac
store all the lipsticks are on display
yeah
to test yeah this woman would come in
she would twist the tester lipstick
which by the way those are clear very
sanitary but they're cleaned before you
use them and when you put him down this
is after someone used oh sitting there
she would twist them up bite off the
tester and hold it in her cheeks and
leave with it that's how she would still
it which is you're my hero I love you if
you're listening I will hit give you
money from the cash app just for that
story when I worked at Sephora people
would you know they had that whole be in
the fly section go and like shop a
little product yeah I put the whole park
in their mouth
only you can stow anything in your mouth
don't steal things that's terrible but
you can and then you used to also have
you would women would shoplift by buying
an expensive cream and then bringing it
back full of something else
one lady did and this was at a mattock
again and it was studio moisture cream I
don't know but she came in and I was a
furniture at this time I think and the
manager she came in and she's I don't
return this cream and I mean the manager
of this MAC store
I mean without missing a beat she
grabbed it unscrewed it minutes this is
mayonnaise and gave it back to her I
just left scooped out the fancy cream
and replaced it with mayonnaise thinking
it wasn't gonna look perfect I mean it
was six world perfectly I don't know how
she did it but I was more impressive
that the manager I mean she took that
her sofa this is mayonnaise my am this
is mayonnaise mayonnaise is a very
specific smell that's an easy thing to
spot alright we have to wrap this up but
I do want you to make that YouTube video
just for straight men on how to put
makeup on to save right some gals the
stress of having to look at a man with
stupid-ass beige spots all over his face
okay we're wrapping this up for the day
I want to make sure that you guys
subscribe on Apple podcast Spotify
stitcher or wherever you listen to
podcast a lot of you guys are leaving
comments you're asking me where to
listen to the podcast I can't help you
it's that list that I just said also
rate review the show please I need your
validation I need your love and
attention I had a bad childhood so
please rate and review the show my
self-esteem is hanging by a thread
subscribe to the YouTube channel
absolutely I don't know what's in it for
you but there's a lot in it for me
subscribe because that way you're gonna
get the videos first and stuff because
what we're gonna do is we have the
podcasts come out the audio version and
the next day it goes up on YouTube and
if you subscribe you get it faster also
turn your notification bell on to you so
you're alerted I you know more about
YouTube than I do but they should
subscribe rise
subscribe subscribe tweet questions to
me so what I've been doing is on
Instagram stories like with Dan levy
from shits Creek and dave grohl I just
said send me questions but also you can
send them on Twitter Benton we'll go
through them all so you can text me
everyone's really confused about this
texting thing the number is eight one
eight two three nine seven five to seven
you will text me it will go to me if you
guys are watching I'm about to hold it
up I get thousands and thousands of
texts a day so I can't necessarily
respond to all of you but I'm gonna
respond to as many of you as I can text
me questions for the guests things you
want me to talk about on the show photos
stuff please no dick pics beggin you dog
pics fine dick pics if you do send me a
dick pic I just want you to know I'll
probably show it on the show so keep
that in mind
eight one eight two three nine seven
five to seven it is real it's not a bot
don't be a dick
is there anything else we need to plug
Dave Grohl just in general we're hashtag
for the Twitter they're close to use yes
there was let me finish I was number no
I totally forgot yes
good for you pod hashtag good for you
pod when you text questions ideas I
actually do want ideas for guests I have
I think a lot of good ones but I don't
want to only do comedians cuz left to my
own devices I'll just have all my
comedian friends on Jim Jefferies is
coming Bobby Lee is coming Busy Philipps
is coming soon lots of
people but I want ideas for guests
because you guys have had really good
ideas and it makes my job easier if you
do it for me
so hashtag good for you pod guests
questions comments concerns concerns
frankly notes for Benton yeah probably
nice ones
anything else no I think that was really
nice like she did a good job I'll tweet
that at you later I don't I don't think
I even follow you on twitter you do do i
oh because you did it for no cuz you did
it the first day I met you are so rude I
don't know I haven't seen your tweets
do I block you know I would know that
how do you think I've done second
episode I think you've done really good
you've held a lot of great I also twist
when you said that
yeah cousin or my glasses um you have
I'm sorry that I also have medical
condition er I don't think you I you
have glasses you have what I don't you
don't have a claim on mental problems
okay that's my thing you stop stealing
my bit I thought you've done really well
really well great you've done great I'm
getting there okay you've held in a lot
of your crazy you you've handled
everything really good really well yeah
well good regular typical you were
really normal I liked it all okay I
don't this is feels very
passive-aggressive you doing great you
got nothing is worse nothing feels worse
for me than getting a compliment me too
I get a comedian thing I think it's just
a a what's it called when you have
what's the thing where you have AMA
no it's where you I grew up around a lot
of borderline personality disorder where
what somebody said and what they meant
were different a lot of indirect
communication and there was a lot of
like everything's fine you did so good
just I don't know I just don't believe
anybody yeah me either
I'm like do you have imposters I'm like
no I had that yes and I also feel like I
always feel very this is quite a
different conversation but I always feel
very like a defendable so I'm like
looking like you did crinoline I don't
trust that hmm I'm a copy gone when I
tell you that do you believe me anyway
my mom other hood is when I give you
compliments do you believe me when do
you give me a compliment come here we go
back to one I've given you compliments
before you have you have but I mean but
you know them I wouldn't be around you
if you would I don't need comment I like
that's something that I think that also
Kamini
have a comment and especially your like
this and I really like this about you
HOT take you you don't need about a lot
of validation and I don't feel like I
need that
I think I'm doing I do need it subscribe
subscribe validation I needed form of
downloads and hashtags yes but like you
don't need something to tell you a good
job i ok then nevermind i sorry it
depends on who it actually depends on
who like I definitely if someone like if
mock o over here one of my producers if
he was like that was good I'm like well
you have to say that what are you gonna
say that was bad I do have that little
inner monologue but if it's someone who
has not gets nothing out of it I believe
it like I'd agree can I finish my
sentence I have a big humble brag on the
way after my special last came out Jay
Leno called me and was very very kind
about it and I believed him because I
was like he didn't have to do that see I
feel like it'd be more real it's coming
from the producer really yeah because I
feel like fantasy for just know we're
both famous all great love you good good
job uh-huh and I would I would feel I
would feel I mean I think that Jay was
serious because I was there and you got
that but he also wouldn't have to do if
I read it to a community in the hallway
right after my special comes out and
they're like it was so good I'm like
okay well what else are you gonna say
you know but if someone goes out of
their way to reach out that's when I
feel like I can hear yes agree with that
that's what I what you just said if what
I was saying I find people that are
doing the same thing it sounds like
we're fighting but we actually agree
yeah we fight over the things we agree
well I think if I look for instead of
complement or validation what I look for
in you is when you give me advice or
like constructive criticism that's more
meaningful to me because if you weren't
doing it and I'd be like oh she doesn't
think I can do that or shouldn't care I
mean that's what I think I mean I think
I always forget sometimes that you also
should rap criticism in compliments like
here's all the things you're doing well
and here's that but yeah I think that
the biggest compliment to me is when
someone that I look up to gives me
constructive criticism because they
wouldn't spend time trying to help me be
better if they didn't believe in me or
respect me I learned and they want me to
succeed
I learned that doing Rito really yeah
because that's the way that you're
taught to give feedback to people you're
told like if we're not giving you
feedback it's because we don't think you
can do this job oh they're investing in
y'all yeah because they really are when
you could hire their I think everyone
should have to work
retail or food services leave three
years they can have any other job Wow
because it prepares you for everything
it prepares you for a lot of things but
also it's just because you treat people
different when you've had to do that
you're very sigasi and you have a very
good read on people like you can read
someone's energy very quickly which
probably a lot has to do with the amount
of retail you worked yeah I think a lot
of that also us do a comedy to you but
but I think that um yeah I think you
should have to work retail because I
think that people that don't have never
had to do it they look at the mall or
that experience as like a luxury for
them like everybody works for them
they're coming into a space we have to
treat them a certain way but you should
treat your customers well but I think
that when you're on the other side of
done you've had to do it when you go
into a store you feel differently you're
like here's what I need I did the
research you're not trying to make that
person's life harder you're more
respectful I know everyone I know that
and I did not succeed as a waitress for
more than I think it was like three
hours but everybody I know who's been a
waitress when they are so much more fun
to go to restaurants with because you
never have to worry about the
mistreating wait staff are not tipping
enough or being disrespectful I also
keep I didn't succeed that's quite a
convenient thing to I don't think
communities can have other jobs that I
would be proof of that I was not a good
manager as a flat you got a lot of good
jokes out of it my favorite is the thing
about when people ask about the price
yeah people say it's um they ask you a
question of like is this surprised and
you're like on the price tag is this the
price like are you sure yeah positive
final answer yeah it's so not on sale
that's what they're saying they're
saying like yeah I just want to haggle
with you like well what if I know that
is this market this is what are you
doing yeah I love hearing your retail
stories we have to wrap this up even
though I want to keep talking well
luckily there'll be more of these yes
there will be more than I can if you
guys subscribe to the YouTube channel
tweet questions using the hashtag
hashtag good for you pod and we should
wrap this up because I don't eat
something my blood sugar is starting to
plummet well I had a good time did you
yeah not a great time oh my god hey
Eddie complimented to an insult it's
depressing
okay love you guys see you on the
internet bye
[Music]
you